george's former president mikhail
sakashvili says he has returned from
exile to support the opposition for
saturday's election he posted a video on
facebook saying he's back despite the
risk of arrest he left georgia in 2013
when his second term as president ended
years later he was sentenced in absentia
to six years in prison for abuse of
power well he denies the charges and
says they are politically motivated
let's get more now from robin forrester
walker here's life for us in tbilisi uh
robin what's going on
everybody's wondering whether mikhail
sarkashvili is really here that video we
saw of him posting this morning of on
facebook appears to show him in batumi
it's very dark in the background it's
difficult to figure out whether he's
really there
but the united national movement his
political parties say he absolutely is
in georgia i've spoken to one of the
senior figures there she confirmed to me
that that was the case
she also shared another photograph of
him seemingly in another town standing
in front of an election
billboard because tomorrow there will be
municipal elections in georgia
so the idea is that he's here
he's somehow been able to slip into the
country undetected
and he's working his way to the capital
where he said he hopes to
raise uh the crowds bring them out onto
the streets after the election results
come in
uh and until that point he's keeping a
low profile uh to avoid being detected
and avoid being arrested because he does
have a prison sentence hanging over him
while he was away as you mentioned there
he was tried in absentia for corruption
and abuse of power but mr sakashviri
says now
is the time to to show uh the the the
georgian public have had enough of this
government and he's really seizing this
moment coming in just at the eve of this
election an important election for
georgia uh to
to really mix things up and um uh to
create some kind of big question mark
over exactly
how his how the results going to turn
out tomorrow uh because his
his presence in georgia could have a
destabilizing influence here
okay robin forrester walker into blissey
thank you